salut brut je suis à paris où chaque
année et remis le plus prestigieux des
prix littéraires le prix goncourt et je
suis accompagné de mohamed homos gars a
très bien servi on y va votre livre y
raconte l'histoire d'un écrivain fasciné
par un autre écrivain africain qui a
fait polémique dans la france de la fin
des années 30 et qui a fini par être
oublié et je me suis demandé si la
littérature ça servait à ça à lutter
contre toutes les formes d'oubli
oui exactement à leur écoute prendre
toutes les formes boubli en particulier
ceux dont on peut s'en douter parfois
que certains ne veulent pas qu'on se
rappelle donc ça c'est la ramenait
toujours des choses des fantômes tout ce
qui est caché dans les placards pour ce
qu'on cherche à déguiser à ensevelir ça
sert aussi à ça bien sûr ça veut dire
que vous êtes un enquêteur alors je
pense que tout écrivain est un enquêteur
je pense même jeu pourrait même pousser
jusqu'à dire que toute femme évidemment
toujours en quête pour trouver quelque
chose en l'occurrence ici on sait ce que
c'est c'est une enquête fictive inspiré
par cet écrivain qui a existé qui
s'appelle yombo homologue m écrivain
malien célébrer puis détruit par la
critique qu'est ce qui vous a appris sur
ce que c'est qu'un écrivain ce qu'il m'a
appris c'est peut-être que lorsque l'on
écrit un grand livre c'est à dire un
livre qui forcément dérange ce à un prix
toujours et que ce prix c'est parfois le
silence c'est parfois la disparition ça
me sens comme on dit quand on est allé
au bout de soi parfois d'autres ne le
pardonne jamais si je vous dis je cite
qu'un prix littéraires ne confère aucune
espèce de prestige littéraire ou même
commercial et qu'au fond il ya plus de
médailles que d'écrivains à quoi ça vous
fait penser ça me fait penser justement
alan ball aux gammes mais ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on ne sait jamais on ne
sait pas si lorsqu'il disait ah s'ils
étaient vraiment sérieux parce que s'il
lâche yves de 68 afin justement son sens
au prix renaudot et quand on lui demande
sa il répond ça comme ça de façon
absolument magistral et majestueuse mais
intérieurement j'ai l'impression de
l'entendre ricaner c'est que pour ça
pour lui est un jeu est et ce qui est
formidable et vous vous en pensez quoi
je dirais que il a absolument raison à
l'été will help littérale nos confères
ne confère pas de prestige je pense si
grand que ça il faut être bleu quand il
y en a un et quand il y en a pas ben ce
n'est pas grave du tout parce que
l'essentiel quand on est un client que
c'est précisément qu'on les entend
décliner que c'est là qu'on a nos prix
nos médailles mais aussi de mes
blessures les plus profondes et toujours
là si la récompense ne fait pas le grand
livre alors ce serait quoi pour vous un
grand livre parce que c'est la grande
question en l'occurrence que pose notre
roman c'est très compliqué à dire mais
je pense qu'un grand livre c'est celui
qui arrive à ouvrir une question
nouvelle
à l'intérieur de la grande question qui
est qu'est ce qu'être un être humain
finalement chaque livre chaque clan
livre pose cette question mais
différemment mais si cette différemment
la qui est compliqué à trouver se
déplacer autour de la question pour
trouver un endroit à nouveau planté là
ça va être temps tout ça question c'est
ça parce que vous écrivez je vais te
donner un conseil laissez jamais de dire
de quoi parle un grand livre ou si tu le
fais voici la seule réponse possible
rien oui j'aime garder peut-être de
quelques souvenirs de cours des des
résumés de textes comme ça où les
commentaires de taxes ou les professeurs
et ils ont raison tenter de nous faire
lire quel était le sujet de quoi parler
un livre mais je pense que ça ne suffit
jamais fondamentalement et les grands
livres dépasse toujours ce qu'il semble
dire et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont grands
c'est plus profond c'est dans le ventre
que sans ce sens on a décrit combien des
gros livres dans une vie je pense qu'on
en expliquant seul je pense évidemment
on paye crise plusieurs livres mais
celui qui est le plus essentiel je pense
qu'il mais il est unique et on peut le
sentir même si on ne le dit pas même si
les autres ne le voit pas je pense que
tout écrivain au fond de lui sans que
c'est là le livre le plus fondamental
pour lui alors après on fait quoi on va
faire la pêche on va jouer au foot on va
apprendre à jouer de la basse tourner
ensemble de choses c'est dire qu'un
grand livre ça vous dispense de la
littérature oui en tout cas je ne trouve
pas triste l'idée après avoir écrit un
livre dont on juge qu'il est essentiel
pour nous d'aller faire autre chose il
ya plein de choses formidables
la vie et la littérature en fait partie
pourquoi vous écrivez vous avez fini par
le savoir non
vous cherchez une réponse oui il ya une
autre raison pour laquelle vous vous
méfier de ce genre de récompenses comme
celle qui nous réunit aujourd'hui et
vous l'énoncé dans votre livre vous
écrivez méfiez-vous écrivains et
intellectuels africains de certaine
reconnaissance au fond vous resterai des
étrangers quelle que soit la valeur de
vos oeuvres
je pense qu'il est important que petit à
petit on se rende compte que la
francophonie était l'âge et que petit à
petit on se rend compte que la langue
française est possédé par plusieurs
millions de personnes dans le monde et
que ces personnes là viennent de partout
viennent d'afrique viennent d'amérique
du nord qu'on pense à haïti lui philippe
dalembert par exemple et finale publiée
du prix goncourt ça veut dire quelque
chose un sénégalais et un haïtien il y
est qu'est ce que ça te dit tu as dis
simplement que cette langue et les deux
papes où elle vient de parcourir et
qu'il ne faudrait pas que vous le voir
que les écrivains qui viendrait d'un
maillage et qui se retrouve tout de même
dans ses sélections lahoud un certain
degré de reconnaissance
ils sont parce qu'on le fait des faveurs
ou parce que ce sont des symboles de
représentativité etc il possède
clairement cette langue ce sont des
écrivains à part entière considérant les
comme des clients part entière il faut
que
pour les toutes les personnes qui
possèdent la langue française et qu'ils
écrivent depuis des siècles puisse
entrer de façon tout à fait normale dans
les lieux où on récompense les livres en
langue française et que ça ne relève pas
d'un régime d'exceptionnalité ce que
vous dites aussi de votre livre c'est
quand même une relation très complexe
entre la france et en l'occurrence le
continent africain bien sûr cette
relation était difficile et même si
heureusement elle se change et je pense
dans le bon sens il ya encore beaucoup
de luttes beaucoup de choses qui demain
parce que l'inconscient qui a été celui
de cette relation là est un inconscient
qui est aussi chargée de beaucoup de
choses détruites beaucoup de choses
abîmée
il est important de toujours l'avoir à
l'esprit c'est une lutte permanente et
sa semaine partout y compris évidemment
dans la littérature et les livres au
fond d'où êtes-vous mohamed moi je suis
de la littérature c'est mon pays c'est
mon espace vital
celui en tout cas où je me sens le plus
libre c'est le pays qui ne fera aucun
reproche kim accueillera toujours pour
aujourd'hui plus que jamais il est
toujours plus nécessaire de l'habiter ce
pays de la littérature parce que c'est
un pays d' intelligence pure et dure
c'est un pays qui permet de se
comprendre parce qu'on y parle d'égal à
égal et on y parle des questions qui
nous traverse tous qui sont celles de la
condition humaine sont des questions
essentielles quoi et là dans la
littérature on peut en parler sans être
parasité par pas d origine une couleur
de peau un nom qui sonnerait mal un
ensemble de choses qui nous empêche de
nous parler véritablement percé mauvaise
merci au buste en images brutes